I have a clip for you that is one of my
favorite clips of the election so far I
don't want to delay too too much and I
don't want to spoil it for you but
here's how I'm going to set it up when
Hillary Clinton had her private server
hard drives cleared you don't just go on
and select all and click delete the way
you or I might right you do what's
called a secure wipe of your hard drive
and there's software for this called
bleached bit that's the name of the
software we're talking about a computer
program right you've got your pokemons
program you've got Excel and then you've
got bleached bit this is not a physical
thing it is a software program Donald
Trump in his unwavering desire it's a
critique Hillary Clinton in any possible
way all the time
seems to have misunderstood what
bleached bit is here's what he told a
crowd at a rally that Hillary Clinton
personally did to her email server take
a look
33,000 emails that she deleted they're
gone and not only deleted folks
hmm this was after this was after she
was subpoenaed by Congress this and not
only that she bleached which somebody
said they never even heard of in a very
expensive fashion use chemical so that
nobody will yeah it's called Clorox disk
clean they've got the desktop wipes and
then they've got the stuff for the
bathroom mold and then they've got
Clorox this clean which you just pour
into your computer and it gets rid of
all the emails you cannot possibly
script something better than this can
you I've asked this so many times during
this election but was this a joke right
that I had a lot of people Jason who
emailed me and they said Trump is
actually being kind of funny in this
clip and I said what's funny he seems
completely serious
what he's saying he imagines that
Hillary Clinton think about it for a
second if you're Trump and or someone in
that audience who doesn't know anything
about computers
you're imagining it's 2:00 a.m. in the
morning Hillary Clinton sneaks out of
bed with Bill who knows if they even
share a bed at this point I have no idea
she creeps downstairs she grabs Clorox
disk clean or some kind of bleach out of
her closet and she starts just dumping
bleach onto her computer servers in her
house right if that's what you
understand that she did I can understand
being like whoa that's super sketchy why
was she bleaching her computer you can't
write this stuff I mean how do you how
do you clean your your recycle bin I
pour some bleach on it after I clean it
out and make sure it's nice and nice and
tidy and you'd like to give him the
benefit the doubt here but you can't he
says she used chemical chemical warfare
precisely to he at if he had not
mentioned mentioned she used chemicals
there would have been some plausible
deniability about what he meant so we
can now add computers to the list of
things Trump doesn't understand along
with the Constitution economics Human
Rights common sense and human decency if
you're clueless this sounds really bad
but of course if you're not clueless you
realize that it's Donald Trump who is I
would encourage Trump supporters that
not only should you be bleaching your
hard drive absolutely then clean with
peroxide all of those little circuits
that are inside your computer make sure
you have total coverage with peroxide
and I'm worried that now there are
thousands and thousands of warranty
claims being made at Dell and
hewlett-packard from Trump supporters
who are trying to do this to get rid of
the records of the porn they've been
looking at yeah I mean while you're at
it you know gasoline matches I think I
honestly think that would be a pretty
pretty good way to you want to be really
really sure that there is no trace left
whatsoever there so I I mean you really
can't make this stuff up and it's hard
to even believe although it is all too
real but this is it this is 2016 this is
the Republican candidate I actually put
mine in the dishwasher sometimes I put
it in the shower
then you run it through the washing
machine you want to just be absolutely
sure okay make sure to give us a like on
Facebook facebook.com slash david pakman
show and of course sign up for
membership it's the number way to
support independent media your
independent media at david pakman.com
slash membership Gamefly is sort of like
netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the David
Pakman show audience and support our
show by going to Gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s